[Musique]
la musique du roi de la pop ne joue plus
pour le moment sur les ondes de
certaines radios
j'ai décidé de ne pas jouer pendant une
période de temps de michael jackson ce
que je veux faire c'est offrir aux
auditeurs des bons moments des moments
qui sont confortables et vraiment action
stimulante la bine ces temps ci c'est
pour moi plus du malaise
balenci le malaise c'est le
documentaire-choc living verlaine
diffusée dimanche et lundi serait du bio
de présumées victimes de michael jackson
se confie sur les agressions sexuelles
qu'elle aurait subies lorsqu'elle était
enfant
des confidences à ce point troublante
que les stations de radio rythme fm et
ckoi ne diffuse plus la musique de
michael jackson du moins pour l'instant
nous sommes attentifs aux commentaires
des auditeurs dit la direction et le
documentaire de dimanche soir à créer
des réactions
nous avons préféré observer la situation
en retirant les chansons pour le moment
de son côté bell média propriétaire des
chaînes rouge fm nrj et chambre évalue
la situation
radio canada donne le choix ses
animateurs de diffuser ou non la musique
de michael jackson se montre le cirque
du soleil présente le spectacle one en
hommage au chanteur à las vegas n'a pas
voulu commenter
donc on a vraiment affaire à une
situation unique
ça va être intéressant de voir les
conséquences d'une force ce n'est pas la
première fois que michael jackson se
retrouve au coeur d'une controverse du
genre en 1993 un règlement hors cour
avait mis un terme aux accusations
d'agression sexuelle sur un adolescent
de 13 ans puis en 2005 après d'autres
accusations
il avait été déclaré non coupable cette
fois ci la situation est tout autre
puisque michael jackson est décédé en
généralement gestion de crise parce
qu'il s'agit vraiment d'une crise
la personne est là pour se défendre et
si on affaire à quelqu'un qui est décédé
la marque est entachée l'icône est
définitivement entachée et va l'être à
tout jamais il va toujours rester une
classe
la grande question l'héritage musical de
michael jackson survivra-t-il à cet
immense tempête
c'est pour marquer les esprits longtemps
parce que sur la planète on est des
milliards avoir éprouvé des grands
moments de satisfaction sur la musique
de michael jackson ici julie jocelyne
boudreault radio canada montréal